WE HAVE A QUORUM --
ANNOUNCEMENTS REALLY MEASURES ON
CONSENT FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO SP
FOURTEEN NO THREE WOULD ANY
MEMBER LIKE TO REMOVE ANY ITEM
FOR THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
I DO HAVE A MOTION.
WELL MOTION BY DALY SECOND BY IN
THIS AREA [inaudible]
THAT WOULDN'T [inaudible]
OKAY -- AM
SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
ROUGHLY CONCERT CALENDAR.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE FONG FONG AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY.
BAKER BAKER AYE BERMAN.
BERMAN AYE CHIU.
CHIU AYE DALY.
DALY AYE FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GIPSON GIPSON AYE
HARPER.
HARPER AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS I MEDIA.
MEDINA INEZ ARYAN.
NAZARIAN AYE O'DONNELL.
THAT IS TWELVE ZERO WILL KEEP IT
ROLE OPEN FOR A FEW MINUTES A
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS MEASURES OFF
FILE FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE AS
THIRTEEN FIFTY SEVEN I SENATOR
GAINES WAS PULLED BY THE AUTHOR.
AND WILL.
WAIT A COUPLE SECONDS FLORA
ABSENT AUTHORS AND THEN LET'S
CALL
VOTE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
TWELVE TO ZERO SO THEY WILL
ADJOURN OR LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS
FOR THE ASSEMBLY TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE WE ARE NOW COMPLETE
AND ADJOURNED